trois vies et une seule mort titre
prémonitoire pour le dernier film tourné
par marcello mastroianni en réalité plus
de 150 vie pour cet acteur qui a
participé en effet à plus de 150 films
et qui avant de découvrir le monde du
cinéma avait fait pratiquement tous les
métiers pour survivre hommage aux signé
pascal deschamps
cette fois la cage des images pour
l'éternité tous tant qu'il y aura des
films et des hommes pour s'en souvenir
ce sont ces images de la dolce vita de
marcello mastroianni laissera sans doute
dans leur mémoire
ou peut-être celle-ci fellini encore ou
celle là le casanova vieillissant
d'ettore scola arbitraire mémoire pour
une des carrière les plus étonnantes de
ce demi siècle
cent trente six films en cinquante ans
stakhanoviste des tournages marcello
mastroianni a voulu se glisser dans
toutes les plus modestes il disait lors
d'une de ses dernières interviews il
avait beaucoup mieux que moi moi besoin
d'un musée quelconque
rien ne destinait le petit mastroianni
avec un j qu'il abandonnera plus tard au
septième art à 19 ans il va de petits
boulots en petits boulots mais sèche le
bureau pour courir au centre théâtrales
universitaires
à force de vanter les studios il
décroche un premier rôle dans les
vallées du bagne enchaîne les
apparitions au théâtre et au cinéma
rien ne destinait marcello au métier
d'acteur sinon une terrible envie de
faire lui aussi partie du rêve sur
celluloïd à l'époque
ap on allait au cinéma pour aider en
1960 la dolce vita le révèle au monde
les offres pleuvent il refuse celle
d'hollywood il faut dire que visconti
fellini encore avec huit et demi ici
mais aussi en peignant nîmes scola se
l'arrachent arbitraire de la mémoire
encore mastroianni devient jeune premier
malgré lui il est le let in over le
séducteur letombe ou continue vous savez
à parler de ses succès auprès des femmes
et à moi vraiment ça ne m'est jamais
arrivé
je vous assure j'aimerais bien voir
toute cette jeune fille venir déchaîné
me demander un autographe
comme elles le font avec d autres
acteurs oui on parle beaucoup de ses
succès auprès des fans
moi moi je crois que c'est encore un
beau mythe une image qu'il n'aura de
cesse de détruire
en devenant par exemple le premier roman
sein de l'histoire dans l'événement le
plus important depuis que l'homme a
marché sur la lune ou en composant dans
une journée particulière
l'un des plus beau personnage
d'homosexuel du cinéma un homosexuel
autant de mussolini et l'un de ses plus
beaux rôles face à une autre star qui
jouait elle aussi avec son image sophia
loren capitale du mali elle improvise
qu'on me concerne il faut se relancer
un seul mot d'ordre faire passer sur et
puis surtout surtout s'amuser voire
provoquer comme marco ferreri
l'entraînent dans l' aventure dans la
grande bouche ou quand il dit oui à
bertrand blier dans un deux trois soleil
il était le père alcoolique d'anouk
grinberg à la retombée en enfance et mon
père ce qu'est la une de l'avenir ce
chercheur en classe alors qu'il pourrait
être si bien au vice roi en train de
siroter son pastis pour amuser s'amuser
et surtout ne jamais faire croire que
c'était difficile j'ai même pas les
légendes qu'on fait si les acteurs
cantine du souffle à huit vous prendre
l'air conditionné l'été nous amène au
studio tout le monde vous dit bonjour
vous avez bien dormi kaka tout tout
avait été réglé bien vous voulez un café
ils vous maquille je m'endors
généralement parce que le matin on est
inconnu que comme ça puis toute la
lumière autour du miroir
les types qui vous fait un massage du
cercle j'adore ma maman à bijoux mais
tient la tête quand il disparaît jamais
leur éducation sgen premier du mans tout
araxxe est là le soleil et vous ramène à
la maison vous avez gagné de l'argent
quelques fois on tombe et même un mot
tombé amoureux de l'actrice ce sont
toujours des mêmes filles
quel métier de merde
certains passent leur temps à travestir
des mensonges lui avait l'art de mentir
pour faire passer un peu de vérité de
l'autre côté du miroir
une journée particulière en italie où
l'émotion est bien sûr très forte avec
lui c'est le coeur du cinéma italien qui
s'en va a déclaré dino risi